mais j'ai commencé j'étais dans un
univers de mecs on voit des exemples est
bonne les gens qui vous suivent aux
toilettes qui vous bloque les patrons
d'aidé que des croix
j'ai un patron de chaîne iii kahn est
tombé sur moi et m'a entaillé la lèvre
ça pissait le sang de part et d'autre de
tomber fort hills mais parce qu'il s'est
précipité sur moi que ma chaise à
bascule et qu'il a basculé sur moi je
pourrais vous embrasser ben oui il
voulait qu'on ait une liaison donc oui
pour que dieu que ça puisse paraître
avec le recul attendant peut-être ça
m'est arrivé tout le temps d'aider
écrivain qui vous propose d'écrire un
bouquin et qui propose effectivement de
bosser sur le scénario ensemble sur les
wii tout le temps alors ce qui me semble
c'est que je m'en sors pas réparé par
les boutades et que je pourrai toujours
tirer comme ça et que je n'ai pas vécu
ça comme des agressions j'ai vécu ça
comme vous êtes choqué le fardeau social
ou pressé il ya des moments dans votre
carrière pourtant le mec vous pointe
dans les toilettes we come here a conclu
que c'est quoi cette histoire prison et
vous êtes dans les toilettes et les mecs
dénis tu ne sortiras pas des toilettes
tant que tu ne m'auras pas fine gâteries
quoi voilà c'était quoi ça la radio et
la sauce c'était un prénom c'était quand
j'étais à vsd aucun journal vs des mecs
avec ma direction nommée quoi il ya un
mec qui est venu aux étoiles et oui
c'était votre chariot marché commun
suivi dans les toilettes non non non
c'était un ami une personnalité de
l'extérieur et qui est rentrée derrière
moi et qui m'a dit bon mais voilà
maintenant il va falloir c'est quelqu'un
de connu lors être gentil oui c'était
quelqu'un de connu voilà qui voudraient
suivre tallec qui massive et aux
toilettes et qui me dire que mon passé
mon bureau était pas nommément dans son
frigo et bastia est rentré dans les
toilettes avec moi et quand je suis
sorti le voile est il était de garder ma
vie maintenant
eh bien il va falloir enfin là où vous
en êtes sortis j'ai dit ah ben ça va pas
être possible là parce que si je me mets
criaient on aura l'air de comptes ou les
deux mais à l'arrivée c'est moi qu'on va
aider et vous me verrez jamais parlé
après et non jeunes moi je n'ai jamais
parlé de toutes les agressions que j'ai
subie jamais donc c'est vrai que je
comprends que quand vous dites tout les
arts gassion que j'ai suivi ça veut dire
qu'il ya eu deux parce que là ce que
vous nous racontez
franchement les responsables et je suis
désolé lisa les téléspectateurs
découvrent sans directement aux tiges
découvre ça je suis désolé un mec qui
vient dans les toilettes et qui vous dit
tu me fais une quatrième du sort pas ça
avec la ccc ccc merde dans mais voilà ah
mais oui il a à moi je suis choqué par
ce que vous racontez je pense que les
personnes qui nous regardent aussi mais
ça c'est la pire agression j'espère y a
pas pire
si c'est que j'ai subi des agressions
sexuelles donc voilà oui nommer les
choses qui sont réparties sont restés
neutres comme ça où je suis c'est le ce
genre bah oui mais dans le métier c'est
incroyable voyez donc c'est vrai mais
c'est étonnant que ayant été tous à tuer
ce discours aujourd'hui c'est des années
oui mais non je suis désolé tu devrais
tu devrais tu devrait aujourd'hui être
un porte parole tu devrais dire je
comprends très bien
moi je suis devenu et des souvenirs j'ai
je vienne les générations j'étais
effectivement un sujet qui nous ruine
on en parlait pas mais tu devrait
aujourd'hui être franchement tu devrais
tu as un étendard et dire oui les jeux
les temps ont changé la notion
d'étendard c'est tout ça mais je trouve
ça dommage drive à la bbc vachon ça
dommage isabelle sur le co2 produit
toute une nuit tout mais dans ton copain
si ce serait bien isabelle ya plein de
gens qui réagissent à avoir les moyens
là sur les réseaux sociaux isabelle
pourquoi vous n'avez pas réagi à
l'époque où on y parle à personne si
j'en ai parlé à mes nama direction à
l'époque mais on a tourné sans doute
l'un des moulins des avocats les plus
influents de l'époque je vous avais
raconté anouma à des réservations
d'hôtel à mon nom à mon nom et c'est je
vois son nom dans la presse tout le
temps j'aurais pu dire à quel monstre et
donné son lent j'ai choisi de traiter
samoa à l'amiable si j'ose dire
je me suis toujours tirer comme ça mais
quand tu dis c'est justement parce que
je suis passé par là que je confonds pas
je confonds pas un propos balourd super
balourd qu'il faut noter qu'il faut
relever avec une vraie agression
on n'a pas le droit à padoue confondre
bien pas de beurre 1 et sur les rebelles
ou non n'est pas de vrai bien sûr qu'il
ya des mauvais parce que chaque personne
ne réagit pas de la même manière degrés
mais moi j'en veux pas aux autres de
réagir comme ils réagissent mais ne m'en
veuillez pas a réagi on n'en veut pas
kenny tiffany
géraldine quand vous entendez le
témoignage d'isabelle qui fait
énormément réagir 1 ce soir
moi je suis profondément choqué isa et
je te le dis je non pas ma chérie tu es
arrivé vraiment et je trouve que c'est
franchement c c c c c fou que ça puisse
arriver c'est le genre de truc vous
cesser et tiffany était déjà arrivé à un
truc comme ça parce qu'on se dit c'est
isabelle nous ne nous en avait jamais
parlé fao voilà je n'ai pas tilté en
tout cas là dessus et c'est vrai que
c'est fou moi je vous l'avais déjà
raconté c'était que j'avais mes droits
de venir en basket à la radio mais je
suis pas finalement choqué entre les
boîtes stein stein et toute la clique et
tout et tout ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est horrible à dire mais j'en
arrive à ne plus être choqué par ce
genre d'anecdotes et qu'il fallait en
revanche aujourd'hui quand on est une
fille qu'on veut faire de la télé oui
est ce qu'on se dit quand on va à un
entretien d'embauché
c'est une tannée de voir un mec et qui
va nous commencer peut-être à nous à
nous draguer à nous chauffer à nous
prendre notre numéro et roule parce que
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on se dit plus
maintenant franchement non non c'est
vrai non non j'en arrive pas je n'arrive
pas encore à la à me dire bon ben il va
plus regarder mon décolleté parfois je
le vois quand même un petit peu mais
j'en arrive pas à ça me dire bon bah
c'est ce qui va se passer accroche toi
ma petite
non franchement j'en suis pas là mais
par contre j'ai eu aussi parfois dans le
métier c'était pas d'ordre sexuel mais
le genre de choses qu'on peut voir dans
le documentaire de marie c'est à dire à
savoir ben quelqu'un qui avait appelé la
direction à la radio pour dire il est
hors de question quel est son nom de
famille à la radio citée dans le jingle
il ne faut qu'il y ait que mon nom est
heureusement que j'étais à ce moment là
dans une bonne radio
il est en train de travailler avec anne
caudal matin mais il ne voulait
absolument pas que mon nom soit cité
alors oui parce qu'il fallait que ce
soit lui le roi hausse à ses os 1 0
il s'appelle en tout cas je vous dit
votre témoignage m'a beaucoup touché ma
chérie mais je suis désolé ce que je
déteste parler de moi donc nous on adore
quand vous parlez de vous et on vous
aime celle assez vrai nom c'est vrai
mais non mais je vous dis moi je trouve
que tu es voilà et samassa m'a retourné
votre témoignage il ya plein de gens qui
l'y disent pareil que moi qui disent
voilà la pauvre isa d'amour et c'est
vrai que c'est incroyable de travailler
avec nous ça se passe mais maintenant
si vous n'avez jamais eu aucun problème
ça c'est moi qui voir c'est vrai avec
grand plaisir
en fait le quand vous voulez